Hello, and welcome to this video on Avoidance Systems.
So in this video, we're just going to look at what your different options are when it
comes to getting AI to avoid itself via this sort of navigation.
So to start with, this is, if you have a crowd, and we're going to see this image
a couple of times, if they are set to walk directly into each other, you're going to see
that you get a kind of effect that works like this.
They're going to ram into each other, and the ones on the edge will start peeling off
after they get a chance.
But it's very common with your standard avoided system, you will get a lot of them
stuck in different areas.
Now, this is hard to completely avoid, and you may have to look at some code that if
they know that they're not moving, then they start to reconsider their path.
But let's have a look at a couple of the options that we have built into the engine.
So the first option is called RVO, the Reciprocal Velocity Obstacle.
So this system, the actors will push each other away, other agents as they encounter
them, meaning that they will adapt their path to avoid each other.
So we can see in this case, we spot that there's a sort of unnatural movement as
different characters are getting pushed away from the other.
Now, this is quite a cheap and simple way of doing it.
And in a lot of cases, it will work.
I'll just quickly show you how to turn that on within the engine.
So here we are.
I've just opened up the top down character to demonstrate this.
Now, this is a function of the character movement component.
So this would be the same on any AI which is using the character movement.
And it's a quick, simple tick box to use.
So if I came over into the details with this selected typed in RVO, you can see that there
is a tick box here for use RVO avoidance.
And if I'd click that, then the character would use the avoidance.
Our next option is to use something called the Btorch Crowd Manager.
Now, if you watch this, you can see this is a little bit more natural.
The characters are actually sort of changing direction, and they are taking the other actors
into consideration.
So it's a little bit better, a little bit more natural.
Now this actually functions as a code on the AI controller itself.
So let me jump into the engine and show you how to turn that on.
So here we are again.
We're in the top down character that we've been playing around with.
And this time, where we want to look at it is, it's not in the character movement, this.
It's actually the AI controller.
So it's going to change direction based on from the AI controller.
So with class defaults, and usually the top selected, if we look under the details
panel, I'm going to search for AI.
And you'll see when it has Pawn in this section here.
We have an option for the AI controller class.
Now if I do a drop down, I will have a few options.
But the one that we really care about at this point is the Detour Crowd AI Controller.
So that is, just by selecting that, that's going to be a child class of the AI controller,
but it has some more functionality, and that's going to allow us to use that avoidance.
There is actually a third option, which Unreal supports, however, we're not going to go into
that in this course, because it is advanced and would require a course in its own right.
And that's when we're using the MassCrowd system, MassAI.
So this is a system built for very big projects with lots and lots of different AIs, and
it's a different way of managing it.
So just be aware that that exists and you can search the documentation if you want
to know any more.
And with that, that brings us to the end of this course.
Thank you for watching.
I hope that that was useful to you.